if you're thinking about buying an  iphone 13 pro right now i would honestly  hold off until the iphone 14 pro models  are revealed because i think this will  be by far the biggest camera update  we've ever seen on the iphone we just  got a bombshell leak from a weibo  account detailing the actual specs and  features of the iphone 14 pro's new 48  megapixel camera since apple is gonna be  utilizing pixel bidding to merge four  pixels together into one the effective  pixel size actually gets doubled which  is going to be a very big deal for low  light photography and videography and  below that we have clear hdr at 60fps so  that's 8k 60fps with extended dynamic  range enabled which is gonna be the  absolute game changer and then finally  dolby vision extended dynamic range with  11-bit colors at 24 fps which will be  the flagship  8k format